hello and welcome to this intelligence
squared event uh with me helen chersky
now many of us dream of going into space
but
in order to get there you need some
pretty specialized vehicles and there is
a risk to life which might be hard to
quantify these days but it's definitely
not zero and until recently the only
sort of method model we had for getting
into space was huge government-funded
programs
you know with all this national prestige
and pride being staked on their success
and and so today we find ourselves in
this kind of awkward gap between
you know low earth orbit being actually
pretty routine for a national astronaut
but no tickets are available for anyone
who's just you know got a lot of money
going spare and would quite like to go
into space
but there are private companies pushing
to fill that gap and our guest tonight
is nick schmittle he's a journalist and
author a regular writer for the new
yorker and he's been following one of
those private companies in particular
virgin galactic
he's just written the book about all the
things he has seen or at least all of
the things he's seen and can talk about
called test gods and it is out in the uk
now so if you're watching the video feed
here is the very pretty cover with the
view through the porthole out at earth
now just before we get started on uh
all the topics we're going to discuss a
reminder for about how the event is
going to work we've got an hour in total
the first 30 minutes i'll be in
conversation with nick
and if you have questions that occur to
you along the way well you can post them
be posting them as we go and we will get
to them pretty much at the halfway mark
after 30 minutes so you can type the
questions at any point during the event
there's an ask question button somewhere
on the bottom of your video screen and
if you'd like your name to be mentioned
please do add your name we'd love to
know who you are but you don't have to
and then press send so we get the
question and if you'd like to tweet to
us you can do that too using the hashtag
iq2. so
let us get up into space uh nick thank
you for joining us today uh thanks for
having me this is really fun i
appreciate it
well
this is a big story and um it's a big
story that you tell from the inside so
we're talking about virgin galactic
which is one of those companies i feel
this one i feel there's a few names you
know this kind of virgin galactic and
blue origin and spacex these names kind
of get banded around
but
before we get to the details you were
you effectively you wrote this book from
the inside you were kind of sitting in
there doing being a good little fly on
the wall
how did you how did you get in there and
why did you go yeah great well so i
think there are sort of two questions
there um the why in the house so i'll
take the y first um
october of 2014
i didn't know anything about virgin
galactic nothing absolutely zero but uh
on that on halloween of 2014
virgin galactic spaceship crashed in the
california desert and and i remember
getting the news alert and
being just like
stunned
and and and saddened that
there there was that someone was flying
richard branson that there was this
foreign billionaire british billionaire
who owned the space company
and they were test flying winged
spaceships in the middle of the
california desert at supersonic speeds
and not only that but there were
actually sort of test pilots at the
controls you know unlike some of these
other companies we can talk about the
the differences later you know the other
companies are are you know automated and
uncrewed and at this point you know
virgin galactic they are early on in the
phase from day one
anytime they light that rocket there are
at least two test pilots in at the
controls and so that that immediately
seemed to me
unique and and zany and
just
full of curiosity so the fact that there
had also been this tragic crash
unfortunately
um
what often sort of draws me to a story
at this point uh i was working
exclusively and and for the new yorker
and kind of writing these these you know
i spent six eight nine months on a
single magazine story and
so right when that happened i reached
out to my editor and i said what do you
think like
we should write about these test pilots
and his response was uh it sounds great
but only if we can get real access and
and by real access it really kind of
meant that you know richard branson is a
very savvy has a very savvy pr operation
and the concern was that
we
go to them and they say sure come on in
uh and they sort of give us the dog and
pony show but we wanted to see them like
we wanted to see them work we i wanted
to see them build another spaceship i
wanted to see them return
to supersonic flight tests and so the
idea so so i went to them and i said you
know you just had this terrible moment
but i want to sort of see how you rise
from the ashes i mean truly and
and so we had a couple of discussions
about kind of what that would look like
and what the what the end point would be
and the end point for me always was that
i wanted to see them i wanted that was
the fourth powered flight and i wanted
to be with them until they flew the
fifth powered flight i wanted to have
something definite to hold on to i
didn't want to end as as some great but
all too many
pieces about virgin galactic have ended
with a quote from richard branson saying
tomorrow will be the day and so so that
was the framework and the the
restrictions were very few the
restrictions were uh you know i said you
don't have to guarantee me anything
eventually i want to be a fly on the
wall but you let me in and if you feel
comfortable you just keep inviting me
and i'll keep coming and so all told i
made 15 trips to mojave and and
was in the room uh for many of the very
critical moments
well we have this saying in in england i
don't know if you have it in america the
um laws and sausages are similar in that
you should never see either of them
being made
is it the same with space rockets
that's a great question um
so i think it's sort of i think that
there are
there are two sides there are two
responses to that truly because i think
that it it
the question of my confidence in the
program
uh it actually
was at its peak probably when i was
spending the most time with them because
i could see how they were working
through problems i knew
the men and women at the consoles the i
knew the pilots i knew the engineers you
know you have that personal relationship
and so you're like alright well i know
that you know john's going to be able to
figure this out
um it's now been three years really
since my access uh since the terms of
that that arrangement uh ended and
they've had a number of problems since
then and now when i look back with
hindsight
i'm like crap you know they're still
dealing with this now in 2021 that they
were dealing with in 2016 or 17 and so
now in retrospect having seen
a lot of what i saw
uh it potentially i have a more fulsome
picture of the way that they're sort of
doing things and you know you see like
well this person who in 2016 was like
the low man on the totem pole is now
running this program you're like i don't
know you know whether i'm not sure
that's uh you know in some so in some
cases that doesn't necessarily lend
confidence but um
but it's an interesting question because
i because i think that my opinion of it
has has
changed
but uh but i felt probably most
confident in where they were going when
i was actually seeing the sausage
getting made kind of in a day-to-day
basis well it's interesting i mean we'll
come on to this later but it's
interesting precisely because most of us
are not seeing the sausage being made
that is deliberate but before we get to
into the details now
there's
stories are told in terms of individuals
you know that is how we tell stories but
it also is very striking in this story
that
and i don't think it's just how you
wrote it it seems to be true there are
some very strong characters here
there are people who
are not necessarily
um
they might not have all the possible
virtues a human could have in other
areas but they are very committed to
this so these main characters you know
richard branson mark snucky mike moses
just very briefly just give us a
headline of the perhaps the three main
characters in this story from your point
of view
yeah i mean mark stuckey is is for me
the main character he he when i first
met him he was always the glue that was
going to hold all this together he's the
lead test pilot um and and the thumbnail
for when i first met him and decided
that he was going to be the one who i
was going to sort of tell the story from
his perspective is that he had been
chasing an astronaut dream his whole
life um through the marine corps through
nasa through the air force and then
through scaled composites which was the
boutique aviation firm that richard
branson hired to build spaceship two
uh he flew the first three spaceship
uh rocket-powered flight successfully he
didn't fly the fourth in which his best
friend was killed and then i showed up
as he was preparing and getting ready to
fly the fifth so for me that kind of
that seemed the obvious choice um
richard branson is is yes is is probably
the second leading character even though
he has less page time just because it's
his vision
um
it's his vision it's his you know he's
the one most most obviously associated
with the program and then um
yeah i'd say that i'd say that mike
moses is probably is probably the third
mike moses is the president of the
company he was the vice president at the
time that i was there
he's this very sort of folksy
midwestern
um engineer uh who has this sort of old
school nasa affect and um
speaks a mile a minute is incredibly
smart sort of like too smart he's
already like he's doing so many things
at once um that had i not been recording
i would i would record all my interviews
and conversations with him and i just
follow him around talking to him as he's
doing a million things and i'd have to
go back into my hotel and just like put
it on you know like .25 speed to be able
to pick up what was going on so uh yeah
so mike was mike was the one who who
could who could explain the technology
to me in a way that made sense richard
branson could sort of explain the vision
and mark brand and mark stuck he could
you know he was the sort of the heart
and soul um but you're right all of them
uh and particularly mark because i got
most deeply in his life um
that was what always appealed to me and
that's you know there's there's two
subtitles you know there's the the the
us subtitle which is the making of a
modern astronaut and that's you know
that's what mark was for me he he was
modern in the sense that he was open he
was willing to let this journalist
rummage through his email files and
everything and just you know kind of
leave himself put himself out there
which i thought was you know that was a
really
brave thing for him to do and it gave i
think a very unique portrait of what an
astronaut looks like in 2021 which is
he is he has all of the elements of the
right stuff all the pilots and the from
the right stuff but he also um
you have a sense of the graininess and
the grittiness and the fraught elements
and the less desirable aspects of his
personality that you just don't sort of
see in those earlier astronaut
portrayals
well let's get on to the technology
because that's that's the sort of the
theater in which the story is told and
so so so this is the the type of flights
i mean we're used to obviously you know
when we look back at footage of apollo
uh and the international space station
you know the shuttle launches and all
that kind of stuff they took their
rockets their vertical rockets they take
off they whoosh up they drop a bit off
or perhaps come back to earth these days
um that is not the model that uh virgin
galactic are using so just paint the
picture of you know everyone's on the
runway where this starts what happens as
a as this flight takes off yeah great so
uh so they have two vehicles that are
that are critical to the whole operation
there's a mother ship which is uh the
white and the white knight too and then
there's the spaceship which is spaceship
two um much like the x-planes in the u.s
of the 50s and 60s these experimental
rocket planes um spaceship two is towed
up to altitude of about 45 000 feet with
the mothership
uh at which point then the mother ship
drops the spaceship the mothership sort
of banks away and then the pilots in the
spaceship light the rocket which flies
horizontally for a few seconds then
enters this near vertical ascent
uh and they then burn the rocket for 60
seconds sort of crest to the edge of
space and then make this um uh sort of
spiral descent uh down to the runway and
the reason for this it's really
important i think for the whole design
and in some ways for
why they are where they are now and
perhaps why they haven't advanced as
much as some of the other companies in
recent years is that
they
they took this design because in 1996 uh
there was a contest to to there was a
contest that uh with a 10 million dollar
prize to the first
private company that could put people in
space
and the company that won this was this
this boutique aviation firm uh scaled
composites and they built airplanes they
built crazy airplanes they have more
airplanes than the designer bert rattan
has more airplanes um in the air and
space museum that smithsonian air and
space museum in washington than any
other aerospace engineer um
but that's what they did and so they
didn't
they just did what they knew and they
put a rocket on the back of it and and
as a result and then richard branson
came in said okay you know i want you to
make me one of those but for with seats
for six so it can you know be the the
the um you know the flagship of my
program um but that's kind of where they
are now and there are a lot of questions
as to you know whether they should have
you know rethought the design ten years
ago as they were kind of struggling
because one of the things is that
propulsion doesn't scale so you know you
have a spaceship with seat for with
seats for one and a small rocket motor
and then it does it's not you just make
it six times bigger and make the motor
six times stronger the whole thing is
just it's
it's kind of nice it costs fuel to move
fuel doesn't it so
things get complicated totally
um well let's so i think that
one of the things so you know we won't
go into all the details of technology
but you hinted at this before and i
think it's really important that it's
very striking you know so we should
probably actually clarify that the point
of this exercise is to make to take
commercial passengers yes they're not
they're not direct competitors with
spacex who are supplying the
international space station they want to
take
people who've got enough money to buy a
ticket to space so it's a slightly
different proposition but what is very
striking so those of us especially who
watch the first uh crude spacex launch
um a few months ago was it nearly a year
ago now can't quite remember um is that
the
if you looked at the space where the
astronauts sat
it was
quite frankly very minimalist it was a
kind of white pod with smooth white
surfaces there were a couple of things
that looked like ipads and other than
that there was literally nothing and of
course we've all been brought up on uh
images of apollo where there's switches
and like every spare space where you
could put anything there's another
switch or another dial or another thing
or a pencil to write down the thing that
you you've just turned the dot you know
the dial to
and
there's a picture in your book of the
cockpit of uh spaceship two and it's
very much
not a white pod
so so talk to me a little bit about this
decision that to use pilots and not
computers
yeah i mean it's a decision that they
well it's a decision i mean it's a
decision that they backed into in some
ways because
because they had scaled composites had
proven the concept in 2004 and richard
branson came in and said okay well you
know prove the concept bigger now right
so so it had already been proven once
there's also though i think really
central to
richard branson's whole ethos is
this kind of his his adventuresome his
his adventurous spirit his sort of
swashbuckling attitude i mean he
richard branson was always going to
prefer that experience to the automated
one in which you know like like you said
i mean spacex is a an engineering marvel
and and blue origin as well but when you
watch the astronauts you know they're
not doing a whole lot they're they're
you know a lot of the work has been done
on the ground by by by the the engineers
now granted if there was ever an
emergency i like i suspect these
extraordinarily well-trained astronauts
would
do something that would you know i don't
know but like on a routine flight
there's not much to do um
so what did they do they went out so
virgin galactic went out and hired what
they thought would be you know who they
thought would be the most
qualified and the the finest test pilots
that they could find
um that makes that makes for me that was
always the appeal of the story
it always there was a human element that
was just
inherently so much more dramatic
there were lives a lot there had been
lives lost there was so much there was
so much skin in the game right um but
it also raises it also increases the the
risk factors multi-fold because you have
so many things that potentially could go
wrong you're banking on so many
on on humans not making mistakes at so
many different opportunities and
um
so so that's that's i think the
challenge that they've run into which is
like the the selling point of the whole
operation in some ways is also its
achilles heel
let's get on to that because there is
this um
this question of it being about the
pilot not the machine
is sort of critical to this way of
thinking and you know that the as you
said the the sort of subtitle for the
american book is about what a modern
astronaut is and so
let's get on to who these astronauts are
and how they think because
it's very striking that if like
so
there's a lot on this about ego right
you want a pilot who's going to be the
top pilot the ace whatever top dog top
man whatever it is there's a lot of
testosterone knocking around
um
this is about the pilot not the machine
and so
let's talk about those pilots and the
way that space flight you know early on
in apollo it was a very sexist world you
know
they got rid of the women astronauts
because they couldn't believe they're
any good any about that now it's very
noticeable on your book and this is not
a criticism of you it's a it's a kind of
comment on the story is that all the
cover quotes on the book are from men
um i don't think a woman appears other
than as somebody's wife until
page 132 i wrote it down no
this is this is totally
and i don't mean this in the derogatory
way it's totally a little boy's story
right
all the little boys who want to grow up
and be big pilots who get to throw big
things around the sky
and then the and that's the point of the
value system right to kind of throw
machines around the sky
is that
is that what we need is that how does
this work because it seems to me that
holds it back as well as pushing things
forward that holds things back what did
you see when it comes to that on the
inside yeah
it's it's it's
it was so patently obvious when i first
got into the hangar i mean there were a
couple things my my first experience of
walking into the hangar um
yeah
it's a magical place right it's a
magical place in the sense of like you
walk into the hangar you walk into a
football pitch
at night for the first time
and you come through the tunnel and like
the lights are brighter than they ever
look on tv the grass is greener than
ever looks on tv and that was a similar
thing when i walked into the hangar at
virgin galactic um you know
there was this like this shortly after
the crash there was this half
constructed spaceship over on the side
it looked like a set of a star wars
movie and
one of the other early observations was
wow there are no women working here like
you know there's like one out of every
10. now that's a reflection of
engineering schools though as well at
least in the us i mean engineering
schools in the us are i think like 18
female
so the numbers are are you know it's
it's skewed from the beginning i
remember having a conversation with uh
one of the um
communication of public affairs people
at the company early on and she said you
know we really need to uh
you know something like we need to we
need to find you more women to talk to
and i was like well that seems to be
like more of a human resources like
hiring question than it is like a
journalistic preference question
um so no i i'm i'm
very keenly aware of that and i'm very
keen and i was keenly aware of it as i
was writing it i was keenly aware you
know my my editor
um my editor my agent uh actually all
the people working on the book uh and
and on the u.s side particularly are all
are all women and they were like yeah
you know it's it's like it is what it is
but it's it's obvious especially at this
moment you know this particular moment
that we're living in um
i
one of the one of the things that i sort
of
tried to do was just also i mean there's
obviously this this personal thread that
runs through it and which a lot of that
is also wrestling with
masculinity and
what have i sort of you know what's the
world that i grew up in and what's the
world that i want to sort of you know
pass down to my children and all that
and um
and it's funny you if you bring this up
just because just today
um
another retired lieutenant general uh a
contemporary of my dad's uh sent a note
to my parents and said you know like
clearly the book is in some ways a
homage to to my dad and to all these
pilots but he said you know
in the acknowledgments it's the
reference the mention that i make of my
mom how like you know all this stuff is
like chess beating you know what kind of
what does it mean to be a man but like
it's my mom who's the one who you know
kind of gives me the glimmers of
radiance and and life and and joy and
all that and so
um
i thought about this a lot i really i
i thought about it i was keenly aware of
it and and in some ways though like you
said you just sort of write though what
it is and and trying to
um
trying to
sort of write characters and make
characters seem
like they're more instrumental to the
decision making than they sort of
were in my in my observations of them it
just that felt insincere you know so um
yeah so it's it's it's a uh i'm glad you
noted the page number
it was just it was just so striking and
it's as i say
it's not a criticism for you it sounds
it feels reading the book as though you
told the story as you found it but it
raises these really interesting
questions about values
and so now you mentioned your dad there
so so let's just briefly describe how
why this story became a bit more
accidentally became a bit more for you
than just another journalistic endeavor
right so so
i think early on
what so i wrote this i wrote this
magazine piece this is this is all first
the first four years of the reporting
all built towards this big 16 000 word
uh piece for the new yorker
and then as i sat down to start writing
the book
you know i'm like four or five years
into this into the project at that point
and i had this moment where i thought i
need to stop and ask myself why am i
still doing this what is what is what is
keeping my interest
and so it was so that at that point it
became kind of an interrogation like
what's drawn me to the story but but as
you said i knew already
um from a very early uh conversation
that i had with mark stuckey
uh that he knew my dad and that my dad
had been his flight instructor when they
were both young marines in yuma arizona
in 1981 you know i was two years old at
the time um
so that overlap
like i knew
that my dad was central to why i was
coming to this story i knew that my
interest in it i knew that why the
pilots took me seriously also
contributed to who my dad was and you
know this built-in presumption that like
well if i'm rooster's son then i must
know stuff about aviation and then
they'd
start asking questions and they'd like
uh nope he doesn't know anything
so
um
so so
yeah so so that so once i figured out
what once the personal relationship was
clear to me and i figured out that i
could i could sort of weave that
storyline in there in a way that that
hopefully doesn't feel artificial and
sort of paste it on um then i it felt
like it was essential to to explaining
um
yeah why why i stuck with this story for
as long as i did and sort of how it
changed me in the process of of
reporting and writing it
well and so i remind the audience we've
not got quite time it's not time for
questions yet but you can be putting
your questions in the uh box where it
says ask questions so do be doing that
we'll get there soon um so just coming
back to this issue of values there was
you know there's this quote in there i
can't remember who said it um but you
quote someone else saying that
the question of whether to go into space
you need a ferrari or a honda accord
you know this question that people are
critical of governments because they you
know they check everything a million
times they have a million committees to
check all the things and there's all
these people like just just put it there
stop just stop messing around just get
on putting in space and there's this
attitude there's this acceptance of risk
which is interesting because you think
that in commercial
flight
that you would want to be even like
professional astronauts basically sign
up
with the serious possibility they might
not come back whereas someone buying a
ticket doesn't but this attitude to risk
and and the attitude to this kind of
glorification if you like of the test
pilot yeah how
is that appropriate in the modern world
like
how does it like do we need that i guess
that's what i'm getting at is do we
still need
now that we know it's possible do we
still need to have oh we need the
cowboys to go out and
you know do these super risky things
well um
so so a couple things uh the question of
the honda versus the ferrari
does it it comes down to that comes down
to the pro like when you're building a
prototype right i mean that's the
philosophy of
you're just trying to test a vehicle
you're trying to see what works and what
doesn't work and elon musk has made this
comment bert rattan who who's the uh the
the aerospace visionary who who designed
spaceship one in spaceship two uh to a
lesser extent
they both sort of subscribe to this to
this to this philosophy just get it in
the air let the test pilots figure out
what the problems are let the test files
get it back down and then we can sort of
make the necessary tweaks and
adjustments um
the
the the the question about like the
glorification of it i think that what
also i found so compelling was that
there were people still doing this
in 2021 like it seemed to me
when i first came to the story it seemed
to me i i thought that this this
life of test pilots particularly for a
private company or like you know or that
test pilot like
i didn't think that people took risks
like that anymore like you think that
you think that we live in such a um uh
um
sort of such a mechanized such a such a
such a uh
i don't know the us is also so different
because it's so like you know
everything's wrapped up in insurance and
and brought you know like
the fact that there were people doing
that that were there were people like
you said that there that were test
flying rockets
that to me was i was that seemed it it
seemed it seemed out of place it seemed
retro right i mean that's that's i think
what actually why it came to because it
was like well what is this subculture in
the middle of the california desert
do we need that um
i think it is healthy to have
i think that desire
to
push yourself
and to you know to to you know to expand
the envelope is like literally the
technical term but i think that desire
to kind of to to explore what is is is
unexplored and and i think that you
if there are people
who can do that better than machines
and i think that that is really healthy
for us as as a society and as as as a as
a human race i mean i think that's i
think it's important i think that and i
think that is
i'm not taking those kinds of risks
but
the absorption of that risk calculus i
think was really um helpful for me at
this point in my life as well by
thinking like what do i want to do next
and how do i want to do it and and you
know putting myself in there putting
myself in the book was like a personal
choice that i kind of you know i sat
there and thought like
do i want to do this uh this is a risk i
could write a conventional book without
myself in there um i think this makes
the book significantly better but it's
also taking a risk because uh it gives
someone something not to like about it
right it's not just like so um
so yeah so i i do think it's important
um
there are uh
there there is a female test pilot at
the company now but like she's not
flying the spaceship at the moment but
yeah it'd be great to have more i mean
this is why i think that in that that
final scene in the book uh in which
there is this this woman who becomes
beth moses mike moses's wife uh who does
become an astronaut
having my two sons watch her
become an astronaut i think was a really
important thing for them too to see like
it's not just an old you know it's not
just a boys club uh you know it's about
it's not just a bunch of old men that
are in their sort of late 50s that have
had these illustrious military careers
that are doing this um so uh
yeah it's a long-winded way of hopefully
touching on your question
well let's let's come back to the
sausages so
this is so one of the other threads that
runs through the book is the question of
what the public and investors and
potential passengers know and what the
engineers know and there's this tension
because obviously anyone who's trying to
sell tickets or sell the idea is like
yes we're going to do this thing we're
ready to go it's going to be next year
and the engineers go um
um
maybe not right how much how much do the
public need like how much does this need
to fly on a dream
and how much
is that just you know a bit too much
marketing spin
yeah
and that's that has changed a little bit
because now that virgin galactic is a
publicly traded company it has like a
fiduciary responsibility to keep the
public updated as to what's happening
but that's also you know i think they
wrestle with that as a company
do we
every day like if if someone like turns
a wrench and a screw breaks off are we
supposed to you know convey that to the
shareholders um
i think it's essential it's a central
tension of the story it's essential
tension of the story because
virgin companies
have traditionally and historically um
not made stuff they have they have they
have repurposed existing industries uh
and you know and made them better and
made them more sort of you know user
friendly or whatever uh made them
flashier
but but they haven't made stuff so like
truly really and truly with the you know
richard branson was making records in
the in the early 70s
but then from then
until
2005 and particularly really until 2015
early 2014 early 2015 when they took
over
all operations for the spaceship after
scale after the crash and scaled
composites was out i mean they went from
not doing anything to building
spaceships
and
that tension between
the fact that the company is a is a is a
marketing company like virgin is in many
ways a really savvy marketing company
that was suddenly thrown into the
business of turning wrenches and
building spaceships
and
um
and i think that everyone i mean that
was just it was a central theme of of it
has been a central theme of of the the
program for the past 15 years is kind of
getting out of their own way
um
you know elon musk is uh
is apparently a very difficult person to
work for extraordinarily high
expectations
um you know he does sort of get ahead of
himself and make you know uh uh you know
give flight schedules that are that are
oftentimes you know ahead of himself but
he's still sort of producing
in the pro you know he's he may not be
on mars as early as he wanted to be he
may not be in march by 2023 i think was
israel you know initially he said he
wanted to be a march 23 that's probably
not going to happen but like he's still
doing some extraordinary stuff on a very
regular basis with virgin
it was kind of like trying to trying to
clear the smoke mirrors away and to see
like what's what's really there and i do
think that um
i do think that they have the ability
to continue to fly to space
but i don't know if they have the
ability to like really turn this into a
the the the functioning sort of space
line repeated operations kind of uh um
operation that they that they have
talked about and think that this has the
potential to be and certainly as their
financial statements suggest that it is
and will be in the coming years
well let's
just summarize that perhaps um that so
in terms of progress you know in this
whole world of commercial space flight
we've got spacex who are now a regular
they are basically supplying the
international space station they are
taking cargo they're taking astronauts
they kind of got that sewn up as far as
i can tell nasa are not building their
own rockets yeah and then these other
two blue origin and um virgin galactic
what's the status of what they're
actually doing now
uh well as of uh today blue origin so
they're sort of blue origin
glorious primary or initial business was
all suborbital space tourism and virgin
galactics exclusive business with maybe
side i mean blue origin i mean virgin
galactic they're they're a sub-orbital
space tourism company meaning
uh and this this gets into a sort of a
nerdy side digression if we want to talk
about what the edge of space is
well it's actually important though
isn't it because i think it's one of
those things where
as a marketing thing like you know
as a as a scientist i'm like you know
it's somewhere in the it's somewhere in
the upper atmosphere pick a point right
where you decide where the edge of space
is but actually if you're investing in
someone the difference between sub or
little flight which is just below the
von karman line and low earth orbit
which is just above it you know
technically a hundred meters makes an
enormous difference to your investors
right well so so okay so
so we'll do a quick sort of so the von
carmen line right is is uh 100
kilometers 62 miles um
in
the united states according to the us
air force they give wings they give
astronaut wings to anyone who flies
above 50 miles which is uh
i think uh 264 thousand feet it's about
82 kilometers um that last part i may
not have that last conversion i know
it's 264 264 that's pretty much i think
you think about right yeah okay so
so all along everyone has always been
gunning for the car the von carmen line
right that was that's the international
accepted standard virgin galactic also
was was aiming for that until
in 2018 they said we're going to space
and they went to 50 miles and they said
you know okay and they've gotten their
astronaut wings like they are they are
those those test pilots who flew that
are are astronauts um
but uh i think jeff bezos himself said
like yeah you know they're they've got
there's an asterisk an asterisk next to
their name so you could see
where this suborbital rivalry business
uh space tourism rivalry is going to go
when blue origin actually begins
operations they're going to disparage
the virgin galactic for saying that
you're not even flying to space or
they're going to sort of snicker and you
know as of today blue origin which began
taking bids on seats for its uh i think
july uh flight i think they announced
that there's a bid for two million
dollars that's already on the table um
so uh
yeah so that that's actually like that's
that's that's the arena to watch and
then in the near term um
blue origin also has a deep space
exploration ambition much like spacex
but they're not they're not there yet
they're not like you know like you said
they're not supplying the international
space station and they certainly are not
building
or test flying rockets like space uh
like spacex's starship which you know
was the amazing thing that does the
belly flop and lands and um most of the
time so
um so so basically there's so there's
still there and the virgin galactic not
there yet they've got more test flights
to do they've got a plan but so yeah
sorry so i think it's helpful yeah so
they they flew to space versus galactic
fluid space in december of 2018 and in
february of 2019 and it looked at that
point like they were really going to
make a go of it i mean they had two
space flights in in just over two months
uh unfortunately they've not flown to
space since and uh there was a there was
an engineering problem that grounded the
the spaceship for more than a year
they had a december 2020 flight that was
aborted they had a february 2021
rescheduled flight that was uh uh um
postponed at the last minute so
they are right now it's hard to know
exactly
the extent of the problems and then last
week they announced that they're all
ready to go but now the mother ship has
some some problems so
yeah they're they're they're they're
sort of they can't get out of their own
way at this point um but that's that's
they're hoping to fly sometime soon-ish
whatever that means
okay so just before we get to the
questions from the audience so audience
be putting your questions in one more
question for you nick which is if virgin
galactic offered you the passenger seat
on their next text test flight
like as um
beth uh forgotten her surname but yeah
yeah
if they offered you that seat tomorrow
would you go
no
i would have
i would have if you would ask me that
question three years ago uh right when i
was finishing this up i definitely would
have
um
but the lack of visib you know again
you know coming back to that point i
made earlier about like you know you're
around the test pilots and you're sort
of you know you know when you go you go
skiing and on the first day someone says
you know you want to ski that double
black diamond you're like no way and
then by the fifth day you're like you
know i feel pretty good i'll go ski that
double black guy i'm like you've been
hanging out with skiers you're sort of
you know you're you're
you're you're one of them kind of for a
few days you're seeing people do crazy
things in the mountain uh that's sort of
how i felt i felt like i was with the
test pilots i was in the centrifuge with
them i was flying with them i was doing
all the high g stuff with them
um there's a little bit i'm sure of ego
built into that as well there was also
the fact that i was about to start
writing this book and i thought well how
amazing would that be for the book if i
flew to space
the book's done so like i go to my wife
now and i say hey i want to go to space
tomorrow and she's going to be like wait
a second what about all the second
thoughts you've been having and the
book's already done like i don't know
about that so so on the next flight
probably not but uh you know like show
some record of of repeated success and i
think that that you know that calculus
could change
okay well let's get on to the questions
uh from the audience here so first one
up is from sarah and she'd like to know
whether there are any competitors in
china or any other country who could out
compete who could either compete with
virgin galactic or outcompete them
because obviously there are countries in
the world other than america yeah yeah
yeah uh
yes so
i don't know of any other private
companies that are there um i mean
certainly the chinese government could
i mean look the russian government for a
while was offering this it was
extraordinarily expensive but the
russian government would say look if you
have you know 20 or 30 million dollars
you can buy a seat on a soyuz rocket and
you can go to the international space
station and nasa hated this it was you
know this is like in the late 90s early
2000s um
but americans and and others were doing
this uh so
that
i i don't know if the russians are still
taking money because i think that now if
you're
if you
if you're a wealthy person in western
europe or the u.s i think you're often
going to now you're going to be looking
to spacex to you know give spacex a
bunch of money to go um then you would
be on a on an old soyuz rocket that's
you know hasn't you know the soyuz has
been in the air since like the 70s you
know these are this is an old design and
it's you know it's like the it's the
ak-47 of rocket designs it's it's it's
it's old but like god that thing is
still chugging along bro don't fix it
right totally
i would i would ride the sawyers versus
of super new modern technology that was
untested because the soyuz has
definitely been tested totally um so
we've got another question here david's
name attached to it um
and it's does the fact that this is a
project that's led by the super rich for
the benefit of the super rich does that
make you queasy
um
it makes what makes me qui what made me
queasy and what makes me queasy is
when they talk about how it's for
anything other than that
when they talk about how this is a
project to democratize space and how
we're going to open up space to the rest
of the world that's when i that's when
it feels
insincere and disingenuous and
just
that that's what makes me uncomfortable
if they would just say
you know this is the way like this is
this is you know it's big money kind of
going into the project prices will go
down you know maybe sometime for like
those who don't have major means you
might be able to fly like i think that
would be
that somehow would be more palatable
than when they start throwing out this
this this democratization of space
rhetoric which which yeah i always kind
of like don't don't don't
don't start with that it just that
that's that's what felt um
i don't know kind of
like i said it just it felt like it felt
like they were selling a concept and not
selling the reality and look the
response to
the response internally to my article
into me continuing to write this book
has in some ways reflected that i think
there are many in the company i know
there are many in the company who said
like nick captures what we do
uh and it's risky and you know three
engineers died in 2007 and one test
pilot died in 2014 and like it's been
really hard and we've had all these
hardships and uh it's dangerous and
there have been a bunch of aborted
flights and you know a bunch of a bunch
of flights that have
you know had things go wrong
and then there are others who say well
yeah but you know nick's making it sound
scary and we don't want to scare away
the rich investors and that's when i'm
like guys like
it is what it is like i'm not i'm not
making these things up so
uh yeah so so the democratization of
space is it leaves me a bit unsettled
sometimes but it's interesting isn't it
because it's not new you know apollo was
all about military dominance it was
about whether america was better than
russia and so that thing of you know one
step for all man
it's a nice line but apollo was not
funded for all man right so it's
interesting how they feel the need to
hold on to this oh it's fine because
we're doing it for everyone when in
either case it's so clearly not true
right i guess you could make it i guess
you could make a claim for the very
first step being uh
it's possible for a human but even then
you know
yeah i mean
for some reason um
for some reason using this sort of
universal language to mask truly
nationalist ambitions seems to be i
could i can i can sort of get behind
that a little bit easier than i can the
universal uh rhetoric that's that's
masking like sort of elitist uh
reality there's so i don't know why um
i like this the idea of this being a raw
chess test for your ethics however
the way you see it
well there's another question here which
is on this other one unrelated topic in
a way which is so um there's also no
name attached to it but but it is that
jeff bezos is you know also working on
bringing people to space and
what they're all it's very notable
they're all billionaires but what
motivates them branson bezos musk
why
they could do anything right why are
they going into space
ah i mean i think i think the answer is
baked into the question because
because they don't have money to spend
on earth yeah right they could they've
it's not i
i mean this is the this is the ego
contest like what what
what human is going to be able to build
a vehicle that's going to be able to to
ferry other humans to mars like that's
i mean what bigger sort of test of of
vanity and ego exists right
and and i think that
um
i mean elon musk had these dreams long
before he had the means to really i mean
he had these dreams way way way back
when he sort of aspired to have the
means to be able to actually sort of you
know to be one of the richest men in the
world you know i feel like him and jeff
bezos sort of swap on a day-to-day basis
um
depending on who's tweeted what most
recently right totally which which to
jeff bezos is you know i feel like
well and yeah i mean jeff bezos at least
just stays out of it stays out of the
limelight as much as he put as much as
possible
but uh
but but yeah i think that it it comes
down to ego when it comes down to sort
of you know trying to leave your mark
on the world and the universe um i don't
know i i i can't that that's a
perspective i feel like i could
understand the calculation i feel like i
could understand the mentality of the
test pilot having having you know grown
up with a fighter pilot and like i had
when i first met mark stuckey you know i
kind of knew
that type immediately and i felt like i
could then write about him in a way that
felt real and intimate
uh i can't do that with richard branson
or jeff bezos or elon musk there's
there's there's just there's a there's
an air gap between sort of the my
approach to the world and their approach
to the world so
and well coming back to the risk is a
question here about whether nasa has
been wrongly portrayed as risk averse uh
by those who have most to gain from
space travel because of course when
people forget you know apollo one well
killed astronauts died when it was
during a fire on the launch pad um that
no nasa pilots have been killed uh
astronauts have been killed in orbit but
they have definitely been killed on the
way there and on the way back um so
is nasa wrongly portrayed as risk-averse
and how does that narrative benefit
private companies
um
yes i i think
and nasa is an easy punching bag for all
of these companies right um
what was the value
of
the space shuttle program you know there
was you know the the the
shutting down the space shuttle program
was seen as the epitome of nasa's sort
of moribund uh
you know this that it reaches more
abundant phase of life and that nasa had
no value to offer i mean
nasa's flying helicopters on on mars you
know like they're
now
there are not
people that are
throwing the helicopter like i mean i'm
not sure what more you know to me like i
don't know where the risk
i don't know what more people would want
i mean nasa said when they when they
shut down the space shuttle program like
they're looking for their deep space
exploration
venture at this point um
so i do feel like they're uh they're an
easy punching bag and how does it
benefit i mean it benefits because it's
the it's the david and goliath sort of
rhetoric i mean it's this you know
burper tan
there's a scene in the book in which
bert rutan at the announcement of the x
prize in 1996 is just
they just announced okay we're gonna
give 10 million dollars to the first
private company and bertan knows that
like he's
thought to be
you know he's he's the he's the the
he's the presumed um front-runner in
this race and he spent the whole morning
just brow beating the nasa administrator
and telling him how nasa is slow and all
this and and you know and i shared
emails in which he and newt gingrich are
going back and forth talking about how
terrible nasa is like what they need to
do but i will say what
what bert's point was and this i think
is a failing of nasa
is that nasa has in recent years
failed to inspire and i think that's
actually like a central theme as well
like nasa it is nasa's
it's in failure of nasa is sort of
you know pr machine if you will to like
show people what they are doing um and
to
to inspire young men and women
particularly women right now as we were
talking like you know young female
scientists young female students to want
to be scientists and engineers and to
kind of uh so i think that that is um
it's it's like the programmatic failures
or the programmatic shortcomings are
there but it's the it's the it's the
it's the messaging that's also fallen
short is that nasa what does nasa stand
for anymore well it doesn't stand for
sort of breaking down boundaries because
uh that's just you know they've they've
lost that
they've lost that narrative and that
narrative now belongs to elon musk in
some ways
well just a quick reminder to the
audience there is still time for you to
post questions so please do that and
just want to pick up on that point
though because i think it's i think the
next stage is really interesting because
basically the problem of going to mars
the real problem is the least sexy
problem of all time it's not a great big
monster to be it's not the distances of
space it's not the rocket engines it's
the radiation that will give you
terminal cancer by the time i think the
last statistics were that by the time
you arrived at mars even on the shortest
possible transit you would have a
one-third chance of having terminal
cancer interesting so so the problem
they've got is right and the problem
with radiation is you can't fight it
with a big stick i think so i think
that's actually that's nasa's problem is
that
you've got this what all you can do is
hide from it huh and that is not a sexy
thing to do you know in the world of
test gods no one wants to be hiding from
the radiation i don't know if anyone
mentioned that in your i guess maybe
virgin galactic aren't talking about
mars yet
yeah it's really interesting um
huh yeah no i i i haven't thought about
that at all i mean i think the other
least sexy thing is that you show up
and mars looks like the least
interesting and least hospitable place
on earth you know it's like it's it's
far worse than like the most
inhospitable spot of the gobi desert and
you're like wait a second why did i just
travel
however you know seven months to get
here so and that is why planetary like
earth scientists like me spend our whole
time going perhaps we should look at
this
but anyway it's quite nice on our planet
it's quite interesting um okay so we've
got another question here um
which is sort of
it's it's interesting in a very
practical way i think this is from
michael and
michael says that you know we hear all
the time that planes and commercial
aviation are not good for the planet
let's say
um
is it the same with space travel and how
does that how does that square with
everyone's you know newly and encouraged
enthusiasm for not destroying the
atmosphere of our own planet yeah um
it is
it's a really tricky question because
it's a tricky question because like
perhaps
one could argue
one of like that elon musk and the
creation of tesla and and you know
electric vehicles is
accepting and
countering
uh
in a way no you know more more than any
other sort of you know big billionaire
who has the you know it's doing more to
sort of uh to counter the effect of
climate change with electric vehicles
but what is the carbon footprint of a
single rocket launch versus the carbon
footprint of you know 50 electric
vehicles or whatever like i don't know
what that calculation looks like um
i also know unfortunately that uh
the average
citizen
in the u.s
probably cares less and which is where
you know all these companies are based
it's probably uh less uh um
embracing of the of the science of
climate change than the average citizen
in europe which is just you know
an unfortunate reality
um
uh yeah i i don't i think that's it's a
really it's a it's an important and
pressing question i don't have i don't
have a great answer to it um because i
don't know like i said i don't know what
the carbon footprint is of these of
these individual rockets like i don't
know how you you know spaceship a
spaceship two virgin galactic flight how
does that compare to uh you know how
many 747 transatlantic flights is that
i'm not sure um i just want i did want
to come back to one thing you said um
and we were talking about
uh
this the importance of of this planet
um
you know
one of the reasons why when i first was
getting into this project you know i i'm
not inherently
interested in deep space exploration or
landing on mars and
i think that probably 99 of the book uh
takes place here on earth like it's it's
you know space is kind of this metaphor
we're all looking up the space we're all
thinking we're all sort of thinking
about how we can
transcend ourselves and expand ourselves
and do all that but like and in the end
those
you know when when you know i don't want
to spoil the ending but like
mark stuckey chases this astronaut dream
his whole life uh and then when he gets
the dream
when he when he achieves the dream like
that moment that i spent with him that
night in which he's kind of reckoning
with like yeah you know that was pretty
cool
but you know it's equally cool and i'm
like you know
like there's a there's a renewed
appreciation i think also for for you
know kind of what this planet has to
offer um and and that is one of you know
that is one of the things that richard
branson i've heard him say that and and
it does feel genuine um
and uh
and i think that's that that's kind of
you know this was always like for me an
earthly book rather than a space book
and and a project that was kind of about
finding value in this world as much as
as you know the ones beyond
um
so we have so there's quite a a
practical question here uh which is
particularly on this type of flight i
think the one verdict galactic is
proposing uh there's no name attached to
it but what kind of activities would
space tourists do other than look out of
the window
um
i mean the view out of the window is
probably quite good yes yes i mean the
view if you go to the windows it is
stunning uh not not much you're not up
there that long right i mean you're
you're you have time for to unbuckle you
have time for a few somersaults you have
time to you know the view the view is
stunning you know the photographs
outside the cockpit are pretty amazing
but there's not a lot of other
you know it's not too much time to do
other things i mean i suspect your
your heart is still you're still sort of
you know dizzy from this adrenaline rush
of that 60-second rocket burn um and
then preparing i mean i will say having
having gone through the the flight
profile in the centrifuge
going down is a lot nastier than going
up going up you know you're you're
feeling the g's in your chest
and you know you have that sort of that
that rush as you're you know as this guy
as it's getting darker outside your
windows going down
it's like coming back from a vacation
except that you're also getting this
like anti-head brush where all the blood
is rushing to your feet you know you're
essentially you're coming back from
vacation you've got the low of like ah
crap i'm coming back to earth now and
uh all the g's you know you're feeling
all the g's sort of you know uh that's
the blood's draining from your head and
so um yeah i was i was significantly
less impressed after doing the g profile
uh once for the passengers and i said
well okay why don't you do a pilot
profile at 100
i said you know what i don't need to
prove myself anymore i i'm good i'm good
for the day so
i can see why they didn't hire you hire
you as a salesperson
well there is people want to float you
know you can do zero g flights on earth
where they where planes drop out of the
sky and i have done that and you get to
turn the teddy bear and you don't get
what you just described with the
horrible number of g's um okay so next
question down here um in the next decade
do you think civilian space travel is
going to be normal or even possible
i mean
yes uh
i don't know what normal would look like
i mean is normal you know weekly flights
monthly flights i think
i think monthly flights are certainly
within the realm of possibility uh
but whether that's i mean i think the
spacex is approaching a point where
spacex could
i mean spacex this year alone could fly
for
i think for uh uh you know
it would be the three of them would be
nasa missions but then there's the the
inspiration for mission for the schedule
for the fall which will be their first
sort of you know tourist mission
um so i think that you could see the
tempo increase pretty significantly uh
will
you know virgin galactic be their flying
weekly flights
like they say they're going to be doing
in 2023 2024
that that's a lot harder for me to kind
of to envision
i i i hope because i've invested sort of
so much in their you know like i want to
see them succeed
because i know
how much i know the people that are sort
of there in the trenches
and i know how much it would mean for
them
to succeed and i know
you know so it's like it's not because i
want you know them to clear the 600
millionaires off of their uh flight list
to be able to get that experience but
you know because i think that they've
they're trying to do something that no
one's ever done and you know you want to
see people you know i don't want to see
anyone fail that's trying to do
something like that um but but there are
a lot of there are a lot of obstacles in
the way and so uh
so but i do think that that spacex will
be there i think the blue origin could
be there as well and i think you know
there there are other companies that are
certainly watching and learning from
from the successes and failures of the
three we've been primarily talking about
who uh we have i have no reason to think
that there won't be other companies
emerging the next few years that that
could easily by the end of the decade uh
um you know be doing this so
so i have one final question for you
we're almost out of time which is you
know you describe being surprised that
this world of test pilots is kind of
still there
you know perhaps in 10 or maybe 20 years
time
these flights will become routine we
think um it seems likely and you know
the cachet of being called an astronaut
well you know there might have to be two
categories because if you're a passenger
astronaut perhaps that's not the same
so
what does someone like mark stuckey do
in a world where there are no flights to
be a test pilot on what what is like is
that what what happens to a mentality
like that when they can't
get scratch that itch
that's a really good question
um i mean i think that he is
i think that his generation realizes
that in some ways they are
the last generation you know military
pilots are coming through and the
military cockpit is far more automated
than it ever was
um
they are still at the they're still you
know the pilots are still
at the controls but there's a lot more
automation happening um
so i think you just sort of in some ways
those who
the numbers are smaller you know you
have you know a few years ago you saw
that like you had pilots that were sort
of leaving the pilot core and going and
being in the drone core and you know
sitting there with joysticks so
uh
yeah i mean i feel like that that makes
that that makes these pilots incredibly
anxious and probably makes their palms
sweat and depressed thinking that like
that would be that is the next
generation or that's that's their life
and so i think they all should kind of
consider themselves very fortunate to be
able to still do this uh at this stage
in their lives knowing that there
probably is not a lot of there's not
another generation of test gods sort of
waiting you know right behind him and i
will just say in the end
the test god's quote is not it sounds
very sort of uh um uh it sounds as
though i've sort of thrown myself at
their feet it's actually was coined by
another another test pilot that uh there
was a vet and this is relevant a bet
that mark stuckey made with uh a nasa
astronaut in 2009 as to who would get to
space first this nasa astronaut or
stuckey and the the loser had to buy the
other one a
dinner and margaritas at this mexican
restaurant outside of edwards air force
base and stuck he lost
and the dinner was in january of 2019
and i went to the dinner and it was
supposed to just be two or three people
and in the end there were like 40 people
that all showed up and when stucky and
fisher got up and they were talking
about their bet and giving the pat the
history there was this other test pilot
in the back of the room who said when
stucky stood up he said that's that's
the chuck yeager of his generation
and then when fischer stood up he said
those guys right there those are those
guys are test gods and so i thought at
that moment i was like all right so
you've got
within the community you have others
that even sort of recognize that there
are some that are you know that have the
right stuff and and that are sort of you
know ahead ahead above the rest and so
uh yeah so but i don't know where those
guys all see themselves or they see
their sort of sons and see their future
cells in in 30 or 40 years it's a great
question though
well humans haven't run out of
adventures yet so i'm sure there'll be
something um brilliant we are out of
time which is a great shame it's been
fabulous to talk to you thank you very
much nick um the book test gods is
available there's the intelligence
squared link somewhere for a discounted
copy uh in the books tab on the right
hand side if you're watching the live
video so thank you to everyone who was
listening thank you to intelligence
squared for organizing this thank you to
the bonkers test pilots who are
apparently still giving us amazing
stories to tell about going into space
and thank you nick and i will hand back
to connor awesome thank you